-♪♪ Blow Your Mind ♪♪
-Now, if I win...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] If I win...
you'll wear this
for two days straight.
-I'll let you go
to Duane Reade's,
get some super glue.
Yeah. Then baow!
-[ Laughs ]
Questlove, would you like to
explain how the game works?
[ Air rushing ]
-Yes, Jimmy.
In this game, I'll read
each of you a mind-blowing fact.
And if you decide
the fact is true or false,
if you choose wrong,
we will blow...your...mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you will be blasted
in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice,
and your opponent
gets their mind blown.
The first fact...
[ As Shaq ] ...is for Shaq.
[ Normal voice ]
Shaq, true or false.
True or false?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, really? Come on.
I...
-Cat.
-Princeton.
-Communications
Analytical Tool. True.
-Shaq, the answer
may surprise you.
♪♪♪♪
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's true!
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What the heck was that?
Oh, my gosh! Geez!
Wow! All right. Here we go.
-So, Jimmy.
-What?
-Jimmy, the next fact
is for you.
-All right.
-True or false...
True or false?
-Your entire career? No!
I feel like -- I mean --
Foul shots wasn't
your thing, right?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But the other -- the other --
[ Laughs ] Softball there.
But everything else,
you dominated.
I think that you've
done everything.
I don't think that there's
something that you haven't done
at least more than once.
So I'm going to say --
Gosh. Only one three-pointer?
There's no way!
Dude, you --
-Get to the point.
-You play --
-What's your answer, Jimmy?
-All right. I'm gonna say --
I'm gonna say the answer
is, uh, uh, false.
-Jimmy, the answer...
may surprise you.
-May surprise you.
Yeah, thank you.
♪♪♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, it's true.
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What was that?
I guess it --
I don't know what that was.
-That's mustaches.
-Mustaches?
-Yeah.
Let me see it.
Ugh! Real mustaches!
-Shaq, you're up next.
Shaq...
[ Laughter ]
True or false...
True or false?
-Since I always watch
"Shark Week,"
I've never seen that fact
on "Shark Week."
-Well, you ever see
"Shark Tank"?
-Yes, I've seen "Shark Tank."
-You ever seen anyone bite
anyone on "Shark Tank"?
-No, I've never seen
Mark Cuban bite anybody.
I'm going to go with false.
-Shaq, the answer
may surprise you.
♪♪♪♪
-[ Jimmy laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What was that?
-It was something --
What'd you get hit with?
Salad. It was lettuce.
There's something --
It went in your goggles.
One went in your goggles.
Yeah, sorry about that.
That's lettuce.
Uh...
Don't eat that. No, it's not --
No, it's marijuana.
Sorry. It's marijuana.
Just kidding. Just kidding.
All right.
-The next fact
is for you, Jimmy.
-Yeah, okay.
-Jimmy, true or false...
True or false?
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] I don't know.
I've never tried this.
[ Laughs ]
I don't know, man.
Physically impossible
to lick your own --
Well, what if you're,
like, Gene Simmons?
He's got, like, a long tongue.
You know? Or --
It's physically impossible
to lick your own elbow.
This is kind of a --
Come on, man.
I think that is true.
It is physically impossible
to lick your own elbow.
-Hey, Jimmy...
-All: The answer
may surprise you.
-Yeah.
-Aah!
♪♪♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-It's false.
[ Thunder cracks ]
Okay, so, it's time
for the final question.
And it comes with a twist.
Excuse me.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds
will be blown.
Shaq, this conundrum is for you.
Is it pronounced
"giff" or "jiff"?
[ Audience oohs ]
-Come on, dude. Come on, dude.
Is it pronounced gif or jif?
-I know you're not talking
about the peanut butter.
[ Laughter ]
So you must be talking
about technology.
I'm going to go with --
Black people say gif.
It's gif.
-Okay.
So that's your answer.
Uh, the answer actually
may surprise you, Shaq,
believe it or not.
♪♪♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
You are wrong.
It is pronounced jif.
-Jif. Oh, my goodness.
Shaquille O'Neal, everybody!
The champion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You won. You're the champion.
You won.
You don't have to wear it.
You can take it off.
[ Cheers and applause ]